io faccio sempre fatica a darmi una
definizione sono un'imprenditrice sono
un industriale chimico sono una manager
pensate che nella vita mi è capitato
persino giuro di fare il banchiere sono
prima di tutto una persona privilegiata
perché io amo moltissimo il mio lavoro e
quindi in tutti i ruoli che ha avuto
nella vita in tutte le cose che ho fatto
ho prima di tutto cercato di essere un
buon custode perché ho sentito sempre
molto forte la responsabilità del valore
che mi veniva affidato un valore che non
ho mai chiuso dentro una cassaforte ma
ho sempre cercato di moltiplicarlo
questa è un posto che è molto simile a
casa mia questa storia che vi racconto
oggi ha una storia di una promessa è una
promessa che ho fatto al mio territorio
alla gente del mio territorio che aveva
bisogno di una seconda possibilità a cui
ho cercato di contribuire per ritrovare
la fiducia e la speranza è un territorio
straordinariamente bello pieno di
talenti pieno di cultura però il
territorio avvitato su se stesso fatto
di piccole visioni sordo al richiamo
della contemporaneità un territorio
prigioniero del proprio passato e quindi
un territorio bloccato la mia è la
storia di una missione impossibile
forse qualche appassionato delle
cronache finanziarie se la ricorderà
anche è piuttosto recente
o magari qualche appassionato di film
d'avventura perché più o meno questo era
il tema però o dei film d'azione però
non ve la racconto oggi non è questo
l'argomento ma è è la premessa il
ragionamento che voglio condividere
con voi questa storia questa mia
esperienza è stato quello che mi ha
insegnato che il futuro si sblocca
quando si pensa che non sia più un
futuro
il futuro è un qualcosa che non si
aspetta un qualcosa che si fa poco meno
di due anni fa sono stata chiamata a
presiedere una fondazione il cui stato
di salute apparente era tutto sommato
come dire una ristrutturazione profonda
ma una ristrutturazione
perché proprio a me io sono un
imprenditore quindi come dire o la
cassetta degli attrezzi giusta per
affrontare una ristrutturazione
in più sono anche una donna in più sono
anche più o meno giovane quindi
un'operazione di maquillage direi
perfetta su una situazione che molti
ritenevano compromessa è compromessa lo
era ma io me ne sono accorta soltanto
quando poi alla fine ho potuto rendermi
conto del contesto
molte persone soprattutto la gente del
territorio voleva che questa fosse una
storia a lieto fine perché soprattutto
in un periodo di difficoltà di crisi di
risorse per definizione limitate quello
poteva essere un unico forse piccolo ma
importante motore di sviluppo un gruppo
forse più ristretto di persone aveva una
gran voglia di voltare la pagina e
chiudere definitivamente il libro la
sostanza cole che di fatto non ci
credeva nessuno e che quindi in ogni
caso qualunque fosse stato l'esito di
questa mia avventura come si dice dalle
mie parti
la ragazza aveva fatto il suo il
soffitto di cristallo si era rotto per
farmi avere accesso a uno straordinario
precipizio di cristallo quindi non era
un premio
non era un'opportunità di carriera ma io
non ho detto di no perché un po come
dire per incoscienza
un po per attaccamento
e credo prima di tutto per un sano
spirito di servizio che anima tutti noi
quando facciamo i conti con le nostre
passioni
mi sono messo a lavorare mi sono messo a
lavorare duramente in un contesto
completamente estraneo con grandi
pregiudizi quando non conforti ostilità
ci piaceva pensare di essere quel
villaggio dell'armorica abitato dai
riducibili galli che resiste ancora e
sempre all'invasore non so quanti di voi
hanno letto asterix però io non ero
obelix e asterix
però alla fine della storia stata una
storia molto molto bella perché è stato
veramente un lieto fine e quindi tutto è
andato come noi ci auguravamo alla fine
ce l'abbiamo fatta
questa storia mi racconta mi ha
insegnato tante cose prima di tutto che
come dire non non c'è un modo garbato
per cambiare le cose non si chiede il
permesso per difendere le nostre
convinzioni
io ho sempre detto che si cresce per
traumi
bisogna volerlo bisogna desiderarlo
fortemente ci vuole un motore forte per
ribaltare il tavolo e quel motore sono i
nostri valori sono i nostri fondamentali
sono quello che regge la nostra identità
quelle cose per cui vale la pena
mettersi in gioco quelle cose per cui
vale la pena rischiare però ci vuole
coraggio e io ho avuto paura ho imparato
la paura il coraggio non è assenza di
paura nella capacità di rimanere lucidi
pur avendo paura con vivendoci e bisogna
essere forti perché bisogna essere in
grado di sostenere il senso di
solitudine che si affronta quando si
guardano in faccia alle scelte
importanti della nostra vita
però la rottura da sola non basta ci
vuole anche un cambio di prospettiva
non c'è futuro
senza una visione e la nostra necessità
è quella di cercare di guardare alle
cose ad una da un'angolazione differente
e se me lo consentite anche concederci
il lusso quando non affrontare i russi
il rischio di sognare guardare le cose
da un'angolazione diversa significa
aprirsi significa a contaminarsi
significa avere la possibilità di
condividere il nostro presente le nostre
prospettive con persone che hanno un
orizzonte culturale diverso dal nostro
io ero un pesce fuor d'acqua
un marziano sulla terra marziano mi
sembra che l'abbiano anche scritto i
giornali peraltro era un chimico nel
mare scuro della finanza e questa mia
diversità mi ha consentito di guardare
alle cose con occhi nuovi
altrimenti ci mettiamo comodi ci
mettiamo comodi nelle labirinti delle
nostre vite con tutte quelle strade che
ci sembrano diverse ma che in realtà
portano tutte alla fine nello stesso
luogo e la vita invece ci chiede
qualcosa in più ci chiede di uscire
dalla nostra zona di conforto e di fare
qualcosa che forse ci può fare anche
perdere parti di noi però andare
incontro al futuro significa anche
cambiare passo ovvero cambiare velocità
cambiare mentalità cambiare
atteggiamento questo è il cantiere del
futuro
cos'è futuro per voi è una semplice
continuità del presente o è una
costruzione di qualcosa che ci possa
appartenere veramente lo dicevo nella
premessa è qualcosa che arriva o
qualcosa che si fa per me è qualcosa che
si fa però il futuro ha bisogno di
eccentrici
ha bisogno di eretici che non vuol dire
essere contro vuol dire però rifiutare i
dogmi il mio dogma era il controllo ad
ogni costo il controllo di una proprietà
senza possesso questa è la sensazione
che si prova quando si è rotto il
contesto è una vertigine chi se la
ricorda la canzone la vertigine non è
paura di cadere ma voglia di volare e la
voglia di volare deve avere la
prevalenza perché se si ha voglia di
volare e questo si sa quando si è
convinti di fare la cosa giusta
in quel momento possiamo anche
immaginare di superare i nostri limiti
che sono prima di tutto limiti mentali
io ero convinta di fare la cosa giusta
anche se la posta in gioco nel mio caso
è una posta altissima era una posta
enorme perché io con le mie azioni mi
giocavo il patrimonio di una comunità
che questa comunità aveva costruito in
cinquecento anni di storia ma io sapevo
che facevo la cosa giusta perché l'avevo
fatta in coerenza con i miei valori nel
rispetto del ruolo che ricoprivo a
tutela degli interessi di quella stessa
comunità
e chiaro che gli eretici non sono
popolari e non vi aspettate che ci sia
la fuori rispetto alle vostre scelte e
reti che un mondo che fa il tifo per voi
oltre al fatto che in qualche modo tante
variabili non sono controllabili
probabilmente lo sono molto poche io ho
avuto stampa né negativa per molti mesi
e per questo ho imparato a leggere i
giornali e ho capito che passiamo molto
più tempo a polemizzare su come abbiamo
amministrato il nostro passato piuttosto
che a immaginare come possiamo
anticipare il futuro
che prezzo a sbloccare il futuro io
credo di aver pagato un prezzo sul
profilo personale anche su quello
professionale e ho acquisito la
consapevolezza che comunque ogni
maggiore responsabilità impone una
rinuncia però l'unica cosa a cui non ho
rinunciato non ho mai rinunciato a me
stessa noi donne siamo equilibriste per
professione anzi diciamo che ormai
abbiamo imparato a mantenere il nostro
equilibrio e anche la nostra autenticità
la sfida di una classe dirigente che
vuole sbloccare il futuro e la sfida
contemporanea
la battaglia che le donne oggi hanno e
che lega le donne ai giovani di questo
paese e sbloccare il futuro di questo
paese che in questo senso ha bisogno di
tutti i suoi migliori talenti la nostra
battaglia e la battaglia per il merito
grazie